Oh, I'm just yelling into the space.
Oh, and I'm left-side, Doki.
Okay, give me...
Hello, everyone.
I'm sorry, I'm, like, all over the place right now.
I have so much work, so I've just been doing
behind-the-scenes work the entire day since 4 in the
morning.
I did it to myself, though.
I fucking procrastinated a bit on this.
I was like, oh, sure, I can't procrastinate anymore, and I
still have more to go.
So today won't be a very long stream because I fucked up a
bit.
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hee.
Okay, past Stokey fucked me over.
God damn, past Stokey.
If you did this instead of playing Overwatch, I wouldn't
have had to worry.
since four in the morning.
Ah!
The cycle continued past Tokyo.
Why would you do this to me?
Ah!
Until as old as time.
Next season, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We will get into Halo soon, guys.
I just answered these replies First and then, and then, and
then put up the game.
I just, oh shit, sorry, that was an echo of myself because I
had to pull something up.
Let me pull up, let me make sure I pull up the super chat
stuff so I can read them.
Not all of them in time, obviously.
I'm already a mess.
But if you're lucky, if you're lucky today, I might be able
to read.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Got to Lord as a flex deadpool in rivals, and my, oh, she is
playing more of the old school competitive game I used to
play back in day.
Halo 2, can't think of a better way to celebrate than
watching.
Thank you, this super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Papa Smurf, thank you, this super chat, thank you, thank
you.
I thought it was just April Fool's, not Groundhog.
Thank you for the super chat, Papa Smith.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, where was I?
Oh, fuck.
I had a train of thought, but I forgot about it.
I'm like, my mind is like, pooh, pooh, pooh, pooh, pooh,
pooh, pooh, pooh, pooh, like in 20 different places at once
right now.
Um, fuck.
Oh, fuck.
I actually forgot my train of thought.
I don't know anymore.
Where even am I?
Where even...
What planet am I even on?
What game are we playing?
What am I doing?
What are...
My Oshi is a mess.
I guess expected.
Oh my god.
Oh yes, basically I was...
I had to do a lot of stuff behind the scenes since 4 in the
morning.
and then I worked all the way to uh to until 2 p.m pst and I
was like I gotta tap out I don't I have to I oh yeah I was
so busy I the reason why I originally looped the intro song
was because I wanted to grab water I I wanted to grab water
and I got three more words messages from three different
people and i was like well i have to answer this before the
stream because you know i got at least like you know i
answer this and i lock into the stream because usually i
miss messages whenever i start streaming and i was like i
never even got the anyway i'm gonna go get water okay i need
a hydrate guys i'll be right back
at least the positive is that i might have actually just
fixed my sleep schedule because i'm so I might clock out at
a decent schedule, like a decent time.
I did sleep early yesterday.
I slept at like, um, oh my God, forgot to fucking save my
Halo settings.
Wait.
Fuck.
I forgot to save my Halo 2 sound settings.
Oh, when was the last time I streamed Halo 2?
When was the, maybe I can remember it somehow.
remember remember the numbers remember the numbers okay oh
shit okay um i'm trying to remember the numbers right now uh
that's our break the sound guy here is sound we need your
help i i forgot i knew i forgot something
remember okay where was I but I might have potentially fixed
my sleep because yesterday I tried to fix my sleep schedule
and don't worry it'll all be worth it it'll all be worth it
when it's all revealed guys it's just right now present Doki
is not feeling it at the moment past Doki was like you have
plenty of time and then it has gone to the top at the point
where I do not have plenty of anymore I we have reached that
point where there's no there's no more plenty of time it's
just it's just time now oh it's okay I was gonna check I'm
there is a chance that might have saved it but it's a very
small possibility that I because Everything I sniped has a
record, and there might be a chance that I sniffed it, but
just didn't save it.
It's not there.
I did not do it.
I did not.
Wait, wait, what?
Oh, no, that's just someone.
Nope, I, I didn't.
Wait, unless, what is this?
What is this?
I didn't do it.
I didn't.
do it guys I did I had hoped but there there there's no hope
there there's no hope none whatsoever unfortunately I didn't
nope it's it's not there it's it's not there I I didn't do
it I forgot that whoopsie doodle all right all right sound
guy we're gonna do this together we're gonna figure out if
the new sound is okay um all right here you go okay i'm
ready now um my dokey coin came in the mail i wasn't see it
says not a scam petra said they give the super chat thank
you thank you yes we did order a bunch of dokey coins
because you know i knew i knew investing dokey coin was the
right thing to do um early that's why everybody's receiving
the dokey coin first so you only have ordered the dokey coin
you're getting you're gonna be getting it um like now i
guess because i went all in on the dokey coin just like the
dog shirts i had 100 belief in the dokey coin so we ordered
them in bulk in advance um and it paid off i knew it guys to
the moon we No, I fucking knew it.
I knew that shit's gonna go up and up and up.
That's how stonks work.
Anyway, but yes, thank you to Super Chat Patrice.
I'm glad the coin arrives safely.
Yeah, but pumping it.
I don't know if this helps, Stokey, but there's also some
specific Halo 2 levels with notorious uneven volume mixing.
So yeah, there's another...
Oh no, I'm very...
fully aware.
Someone that played Halo 1 on stream.
I am fully 100% aware of the fucked up sound balancing that
the remaster provides it.
Because even though it's remastered, apparently the audio
wasn't invited to the show.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, I will not be doing any hard Easter eggs.
Anything that requires me to fucking watch a tutorial video
on how to figure that shit out.
But I can't.
But I will not be doing that.
I will.
But but the scare of the gun.
Anything that requires me to watch a tutorial video.
to obtain whatever it is would most likely not happen only a
40 but bro it's only a 40 minute tutorial bro it's so guys
guys this is your pleasure for so he has that swimsuit or
yesterday may your sound be cursed simple thank you for for
the super chat, thank you, thank you, but bro, it's so worth
it, bro, come on, bro, it's so fucking, guys, guys, we don't
have much time today, guys, please, we don't have much time
today, if it requires me to watch a tutorial video, most
likely, I do not think that you guys, will assist me in
obtaining whatever you want me to obtain.
Do you really think I can follow a step-by-step guide
constructed by my own chat?
By like 40 plus different people trying to guide me to
whatever the fuck it is you wish to guide me to?
No, I'm not saying that you can't help me.
I'm saying that you guys as a group with very different
skill sets of explaining things might not lead me to
success.
Just a maybe.
Especially if this tutorial video Originally, for whatever
the fuck it is you want to guide me to, it's known to be
very hard to understand.
So I think it might be harder if with no visual guides, I
just followed the word of chat.
When have we ever led you astray?
Apparently, I have a unique set of skills, which includes
getting one guide.
reading just picking the one chatter that says the wrong
thing out of the group like
wait like i some of you guys might be locking in but i'll
still somehow pick the one guy that will say something
different i'll be like all right i'll try that i'll try
That is all I'll be like, all right, all right, yeah, you
know, this is like all people are saying, I'll try, but it
was just one guy that said it.
It was just, it is a very handy skill in the streaming, in
the streaming world, but for today, it might not be useful
for today.
That's right, baby, I always give the wrong info.
All right, what else?
Oh, yeah.
Also, I rewatched like, oh, my God, already took you already
used up 23 minutes, but I'm still going to go for it.
I remember rewatching the VOD from the last stream because I
was like, how fuck did I do this goddamn legendary mode?
And then I didn't realize.
The thing is, I didn't realize.
for two hours straight everyone was yelling at me to do the
combo but like and then like people were even like super
chatting me being like here's the combo that you have to do
to make it easier but you guys don't understand when i'm
getting absolutely destroyed the thoughts in my head it's
just like i need a oh please god i don't want to die please
i just want to stay alive oh my god please I felt like I was
actually in no man's land I was like I was like a soldier
that got drafted uh I got automatically drafted to war in no
man's land just turned 18 and I'm like like oh but I hope I
get to see my family like I'm just like shell shocked and
like your advice went from one ear to the other.
I was just like, just got dropped in the front lines eating
my stale-ass cookies that were sent from home three months
ago.
And I was just like, I gotta survive.
I have to survive the trenches.
Oh my God, is that Gerald?
I talked to him yesterday.
Oh my God, it was his birthday.
I was there at his birthday yesterday.
Oh, No, I was stuck in pure panic.
Hold the line, Toki.
Hold the line.
So, so that's like I couldn't like take in any of the
fucking information.
Because the moment I spawn in, it's like if I don't show up,
Shoot, if I don't do any, like if I just spend one second
comprehending whatever the fuck was going on in chat, I die.
I, it was just survival mode.
I, like, I had to learn, like, like learn from, from the
beginning.
From trial and error.
One of the buttons, comments I told you to use was useless.
I was hoping you see a no one else.
Like, I'm pretty sure the one time, like, except the couple
of times I, like, was able to re-chat.
I, like I said, I have a very special particular set of
skills where I can somehow read the wrong advice out of the
20 helpful advice in chat.
I will pick the one guy that was like, what if I say, well,
what if I spread misinformation today?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doctor, thank you for the super chat.
It's like those monks meditating on their waterfall.
All the lights just get sewn up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I also saw some people were like, oh my God.
How does she not notice?
Does she play FPS games?
I need you guys to know, for those who are new here, I
didn't grow up with shooters.
So I've never grown up with the traditional shooters that a
lot of people play FPS games now like, you know, no So I
don't actually a lot of like basic info that like a lot of
people grew up with when they play like the old school
shooters I didn't know about because like I my first shooter
was literally Splatoon Like I was not raised on the
traditional old school stuff So like there's like some
things like that might be like What's it called might be
like ingrained for people um that because it's like always
there during the old school stream i don't know about i
never grew up with it so i'm like learning it's basically
every time i play like old school stuff i was just like oh i
didn't know this mechanic existed what yeah so i grew up on
the first shoot i ever played was platoon and then and then
it was overwatch and then it was apex and then um rivals
that was Yeah, the muscle memory.
I never developed muscle memory that came from playing like
the old school shooters because I never played the old
school shooters.
I never played Halo.
I watched my dad play Gears of War.
I never played Quake.
I never played...
I watched my dad play Serious Sam.
I never played it myself.
I never played Doom or anything.
I literally just go Splatoon, Overwatch, Apex, Ravos, and
then back to Overwatch.
We're going backwards a little.
So, like, it's actually crazy.
That's why I hate using numbers to switch weapons.
Because every time, you know, because in Overwatch, whenever
I have to play, like, the more older shooters, people are
more used to using numbers to swap weapons.
But it frustrates me sometimes.
It frustrates me so much.
Because I don't have to press numbers when I play Overwatch
or when I play Apex, because I just use my scroll wheel.
but like you yeah and then and then there's no scroll wheel
in like the older shooter games and then it's like i was
like ah i remember i had to like yeah i was like rebuy i had
to rebuy the stuff because i was just like i don't
understand i i have to move my index finger a little bit
higher like I was just like why do I have to move my index
finger a little higher to press these buttons it's just so
inconvenient it's just um uh she wouldn't survive it I think
I actually played like didn't use the binds as much i used
to play rts growing up um but i was like casual i didn't
play multiplayer i just played like story mode um and like
that because i was a child i was a little kid and i don't
didn't i was like i don't think my parents wanted me to play
multi like go into the multiplayer world as a child against
the the the adults the Koreans adults too like they're crazy
I remember like growing up um because I went to
international school um I went to an international school
and uh and uh one of my international schools had a lot of
Korean students because of Samson um and uh um and because
of that like you know there was a lot of Samsung employees
uh located there so so then uh I and then they would like
invite me over and then they would just be playing Starcraft
and everything and then they're like oh you like oh hey
let's let's play together and I would then it would be like
and I was just like I love Starcraft I grew up playing
Starcraft I fucking love that game and I was like yeah let's
play and then I'll just be like
Yeah, because I never played multiplayer before.
I never played like the fucking 600 plus APM.
No, no, it's like, because StarCraft was such a huge thing
in Korea.
And it was true.
Like, like a lot of my friends, well, a lot of guy friends
played StarCraft.
But they were, they did compliment me.
They were like, wow, oh my God, you survived pretty longer
than I thought.
Like, you know, I take that as a compliment.
They're like, oh, you survived longer than I thought.
Like, because they didn't thought I would die right away.
But I held out.
I held out for a while.
Before I died, I held out longer than they expected.
um so um but yes i but it was it was crazy when i first saw
what multiplayer was like i was like i think i'm pretty good
i i play story mode and i did really well in story mode i
was like i think i'm pretty good at this game and play
against cpu and i played against cpu you know um obviously
and it's not the same it's not the same i was playing as
real people i was just like i should be okay like i was like
you know they're my age um so like we should be around the
same skill level it was not the same it was not it's the
same i swear i got in and then the first like one minute
they already said fucking they already sent like zergs at me
and i was just like i remember i was just like i'll be okay
Okay, I mean, surely that's the end.
And then it never stopped.
It never stopped.
The Zerglings never stopped coming.
They never, they never stopped coming.
I think that was when I was first introduced to the Zerg
rush, like from a real person, not from the CPU or like the
story mode.
I just gotta survive this, right?
And then it'll, it never stopped.
It's just, you're coming.
Anyway, let's play.
Let's play Halo.
Like I said, today's not going to be a super long stream
today.
Just because Past Doki thought it was the funniest prank
ever.
She just thought it's so funny.
You know, what a future Doki had to fix all of Past Doki.
rookie's mistakes.
They just keep coming, and they just keep coming.
Congrats on winning a game.
Congrats on not getting immediately murdered.
Cooler, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Oh.
I forgot like also it's like fucky wucky the this stream
stuff is because I'm tabbing in and out because like my
monitor is 500 this is the most frustrating part about it it
is black stream because I need to get into halo 2 because
that's for you know you have to boot it up because it's 500
hertz but because my other monitors aren't 500 hertz it
messes with it but I could I mean can I do window it's a
window mode let me double check because usually I can bypass
it if I play on window mode and not let it pull the screen
all right let's do all right borderless maybe that'll fix it
oh all right save settings so that I could tab in and out
hey dokey today is my birthday can you get happy birthday
please yes day after April Fool's Day makes it annoying but
I love it's uh thank you my super chat thank you thank you
hey at least it's not it's not during April Fool's Uh, wait,
actually, that sucks you missed out on like having a happy
birthday song sung during April Fool's
Wait, wait, wait, wait, actually, actually though, actually,
um, even though, even though it's not April Fool's For your
birthday, uh, I'll do something a little special just, uh,
just for you.
This is an exception that
It's just, there's an exception.
How, hello there.
Oh, wait.
Um, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Hello, everyone.
I'm sexy dokey.
Here, I heard it's someone's special day.
I heard it's someone's special day.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear taco.
birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Okay, let's swap back.
Let's...
Oh, you have a great birthday taco.
You're welcome.
I know that I know you wish your birthday was on April
Fool's but don't worry don't worry I got you I got you all
right all right let me see that's this is why Kinder eggs
were outlawed golden thank you with a super chat thank you
thank you do you guys see the current like everybody is like
I'm sorry that you're Canadian tweets
peter thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
speaking of starcraft the game was one of halo's
inspirations uh aside from avp marathon starcraft is itself
almost had third-person shooter and even an fps but we can't
have night i remember that they were planning on developing
the ghost one was it like the ghost uh spin-off where it was
like uh but it got cat they were in development for so long
and then it got canceled it made me so i was looking forward
to it too I remember like looking like looking up like
updates and like uh looking like reading up about it um and
then being sad it got canceled because it looked really good
um yeah the Nova games
um let's see wait when did it get canceled wait Starcraft
Nova because I remember it was like in development for so
fucking long just to be like scrapped in the end yeah it was
announced in 2002.
And they had, like, trailers and everything come out, too.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Stop!
You violated the law of my eyes.
Paint a quarter dragon with the fine of playing a legendary
or serve your sentence.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Duck, knock, knock.
I noticed the pictures aren't uploaded on the archive,
Knock, knock.
Why is there only one picture of the new dokees, huh?
Huh, Doug?
Come on.
Sexy doke had a lot of faces there.
You don't own the web.
I uploaded them and out at you.
Let me check.
Let me check, Duck.
Like, unfortunately.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, but it's missing.
It's missing a lot of things.
But Sexy Doki had so much to show.
Why is it interesting?
incomplete what
one thank you for the super chat thank you thank you wait i
have to find oh fuck i i just i have to get it's true for a
lot but i have to find this particular picture um wait it
might be my history because i was like ha ha
um wait i need to find this sorry i have to find the
specific tweet about canadians i had to I thought it was so
fucking funny.
Okay, wait.
X.
I keep forgetting.
It's not X.com.
But there's like a certain... There's like a trend right now
about being like...
My condolences for being Canadian.
It's like everywhere right now.
And I have to show it.
I was like, oh shit, I should save this.
And then I forgot to save it.
I'm so sad.
like oh my god that's me that and then i forgot to save it
i'm making me so sad now okay the worst part is like i don't
know if i saw it on my phone or if i saw it on uh i saw it
on on uh on twitter on oh wait on my pc okay i don't know
where is it wait i'm sorry for being in that Twitter.
Okay, all right, I'll describe it.
So it was like, it looked like this really like angsty
illustration.
And then, and then, like, it's like this cat.
I think it was a cat.
And then it was a super angsty illustration where like he's
surrounded he's surrounded by like all these other shadow
people and he's like Canadian Canadian Canadian Canadian
he's like Canadian Canadian and then the cats having a
breakdown and crying and the last I was like I'm so sorry
for being Canadian I'm but it was it went so well.
Being with the art.
We have a sparkling water where I live called Clearly
Canadian.
I'll buy some for in your honor.
Paturess said thank you for the simper chat.
Thank you.
It was pretty funny.
I was just like, what the
wait, I think I found it.
Okay, I found the first paddle.
No!
I found the first paddle of the comic wait okay wait wait
you guys might reckon i wish i have the full comic though
wait i could google reverse google search reverse guys i'm
already i'm like i i i'm in too deep now oh Shit, my Chrome.
I have too many tabs.
My Chrome froze.
Oh my god.
No.
My Chrome froze.
I went too far.
Oh no.
Oh wait.
Wait.
It's recovering.
When are you gonna play?
As soon as I find this picture, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm going to find it.
Okay, wait, I'll open up.
I'll open up.
It's not Edge anymore, right?
Okay, it's still Edge.
Okay, I'm going to say, I remember they were like, we're
shutting down Microsoft Edge.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Okay, I'm opening up.
All right, reverse Google search.
All right.
I need to find that.
Guys, you don't understand.
Oh my God.
Wait.
Okay.
It's not the original.
It's not the original, but, like, it's, like, almost there.
Okay, here you go.
It's not the original one that I wanted to show you guys.
But, like, these are some of the stuff I've been seeing on
my Twitter.
There's a lot of text still.
There's a lot of Twitter texts about it.
Let's see.
Oh, there's Ugly Sonic.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, shit.
Where did it go?
Oh, wait.
Here it goes.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I
Canadiens it when you try to find the Canadian version of
this particular picture, but it's like But like the but the
edit because it was edited and the other edit for it.
I cannot show on stream Like the original edit of it, but
someone made a Canadian version of it and I I need to find
the Canadian version of this.
There is a...
Oh, wait.
Wait, I found...
I found the Weeb one.
Wait, what is it?
Oh, wait.
No, WebP.
Let me say I could find the Canadian version.
Guys.
Okay.
Let me say I could find it.
Canada.
Canadian Maybe if maybe I could find the Canadian version of
this I found the Australian version Wait Is this the No I
only I can only find I can only find the The Australian
version of it Not the Canadian the Canadian one but yes it
was basically like that but like canada missed out on recent
stream but saw the club penguin clip as a latino dragon i
always invited some good fajitas and flautas uh superior
superior thank you was chat thank you thank you anyway but
yeah sorry let me go play the game now i'm sorry i really
had to i really had to show that particular picture I it was
just it was in my head for so long guys you don't understand
SK thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I didn't
know I'll be catching strings during capping session thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you it's okay you can
join me okay you can join me Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, now we play the game.
I can't find...
I can't find a Canadian version.
So we're just gonna play now.
Alright, no more distractions.
Resume.
Oh, thank God.
I thank God I don't have to...
Okay, I fixed it.
I went window mode.
Alright, here we go.
Found the Canadian.
What do you mean now it is?
This game is not in screen.
Alright, I need to remember the controls again, guys.
Alright, melee.
Okay.
Okay, my two items.
Um.
Alright.
Alright, we're good to go.
We're good to go.
We just gotta drive the scorpion.
It's tank time.
God, that is so...
a slow tank never again oh so apparently i found out that
that was crazy for trying legendary for all but for the
first as a first timer because apparently it's known as the
hardest fucking um i finally did my research not about this
game obviously like not about like the overall what the is
going on in this game type research but it's more so like
being like a legendary uh run in Halo 2 is the hardest
hardest legendary run ever in all of Halo in all of Halo
Halo 2 is when things get really really hard and apparently
it's crazy of me to try and do it as a first timer but by
God I'm not easily bribable if you oh my God if I can I will
monetize my pain.
Dense.
I would be the dense monkey dense.
And I would be like, how much do you want me to dance?
Do you want me to do a little jump, do a little jig?
Do a little jig too.
How is my tank almost dying?
a goddamn tank what are my taxpayers paying for hello this
is my 500 million million dollar like no that's too little
this is my five trillion military budget oh there's a
machine gun i did not know that oh just like big explosion
okay here we go oh my god i can't move now Okay, now this
tank is fucked.
Okay.
Oh shit, that's my- He's okay.
Oh shit.
Can't stop reflex, guys.
I can't stop reflex.
Oh yeah, wait, sound yet.
It's the sound- okay.
the other two clicks.
It only brought the overall two clicks in game.
It was my overall.
Oh.
Yeah.
I mean, I could go down.
Should I go down?
Go down a little.
Alright.
Oops.
That's a little oopsie.
It's alright.
military will send their family benefits the military will
take care of their family guys it's okay don't worry their
their wife and kids will at least you know will be inspired
to keep on enlisting as revenge they'll be like your dad got
killed by those goddamn aliens and you'll be like I'm so mad
I'm gonna enlist just like my father so I can get revenge
Look at that.
I'm helping.
They're like, I'll get my revenge for what they did to my
dad.
And like, yes, the aliens killed him.
Yes, the aliens.
It's all...
Oops.
That's right.
And I'm helping.
USA.
Spunk.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, your dad.
You're like, your dad died with honor and not from an
accident.
John Halo.
No, no, no.
It's all the aliens.
It's like, no.
goddamn aliens get out of here zino this is my galaxy usa
usa
you and i see tank beats everything oh shit i might have got
a little too close to that that guy oh wait but i'm full hp
now what the Oh wait, I am not full HP.
That's just my shield.
I just realized that was just my shield.
That's quite a while.
U-E-G, U-E-G.
All right, there we go.
Okay, we gotta make sure it's not too close to me though.
I'm so fine.
Bomb!
Boom!
Get out of here!
That's right.
You, you, you, you.
We're here for democracy!
We're gonna save the galaxy!
Get out of here, aliens!
Welcome to Earth, motherfucker!
Oh shit, oh shit, they're trying to welcome me.
Wait, I didn't mean now.
I didn't mean, I didn't mean now, though.
I didn't need the welcome party now, guys.
It's alright.
It's okay.
We can reschedule.
We can reschedule the welcoming party.
I'm a little busy today.
Alright.
The U.S.C.
isn't really about democracy.
Oh my god.
A traitor.
It's always about democracy.
It's the foundation.
It's the hidden agenda.
Sounds like what an alien would say.
Alright.
What are you okay?
I don't know, I got really inspired when I got in the tank.
I got a bit too immersed.
Yoki is joking, but quick friend with it.
There's a legit Halo XL damage to your crossover.
So it's not entirely inaccurate.
aliens say wart oh
he said wart guys guys he said wart look someone lived so
guys an alien got him we're gonna tell their families those
goddamn aliens killed another honest good man Toki why wait
can I oh Oh my god, how could the aliens do this?
How could they're so cruel?
How could they do this to America?
Wait, was there someone behind me?
Okay, that one.
Who the fuck stands behind a tank?
That's all I'm gonna say.
He stands behind a tank.
It is our earth.
Okay, here I'm never...
Was there someone behind me?
Okay, that's on them.
They literally stood behind.
They stood behind a goddamn tank.
They were asking for that.
Wait, there's a shotgun.
good where that's just oh wait look ammo oh my god oh fuck
oops
where's the shotgun oh there it is but like i have this
though the smart guy not standing in front of a tank look
gross thank you in the super chat thank you thank you i'm
gonna I guess I could swap it for that.
I guess.
Wait, how do I?
Someone said...
I know there's a flashlight, but like, it's not buying to
anything convenient.
What, guys?
What button is flashlight?
I'm pressing the letters.
You're going to be court-martialed, and you're laughing.
What do you mean?
I didn't do nothing.
The Zenos got them.
Oh my god, it's a four.
That is so inconvenient for me.
Oh my god, whoops.
They don't stop shooting.
This is bad.
Alright.
Whoa!
There we go.
Okay, now I don't have bullets no more.
Alright, I'm getting rid of the shotgun.
I need the combo.
Is this a combo?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's the sniper.
I was like, was that easy sniping?
Alright, even if I had teammates, they were just gonna die
in two seconds.
Can't trust nobody.
Why is he still alive?
What the fuck?
Okay.
He's just standing there.
He's asking to get shot.
My flashlight is literally outright.
Wait, I could do this.
Okay, I didn't realize guys, I didn't realize that it's
tight quarters on the other side, sir.
Use this.
Thank you.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Okay, guys.
I didn't realize.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Maybe I got a little too cocky there.
See, she's dead!
I told you guys!
Like, what was the point?
She's just gonna die anyway.
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, shit.
Oops.
I was trying to...
What the fuck?
I told you she was just gonna die.
Okay, now this guy was gone.
I can't see shit.
Oh?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Yeah, I gotta recharge.
Here we go.
See?
Everything is fine.
Oh.
Man.
Could just get rid of these guys.
Should we?
Come on, peek me.
There we go.
Easy.
Okay, and then we'll grab...
Grab this.
Because I don't have bullets.
I know there was one more sniper guy up here.
Oh, shit!
Okay, give me a sec.
Maybe Kobe.
Oh, shit.
Wait, they came over?
I didn't have bullets.
That's okay.
I can do this again.
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, I see you guys.
Shotguns suck.
Wait, let's just pierce this through the armor anyway.
I'll just wait for him.
Come on.
I know you're right there.
What's that sound?
Wait a minute, what the fuck is that sound?
Also, a little pussy?
Alright, let's swap this back to the rifle.
I'm sure, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
It's gone forever.
What?
How is this gone forever?
Okay.
Maybe I can grab the other one?
Oh my god.
Well, never mind.
It's just God.
It just doesn't exist anymore.
It's just...
Yeah, but I wanted to hold it.
Is that too much to ask for?
I just wanted to hold its head.
Grab a new one.
I should have might as well grab double.
Wait, I want to dual wield this.
I can't dual wield this?
I can't have anything.
Oh my gosh.
I should make my own laws.
My own rules.
I'm literally John...
I can't...
Where is...
Where's my cross?
Oh, there you go.
I was like, where's my cross here?
What?
Who shot that?
what the fuck that god god's that you
okay he shot it when he died oh okay that makes more sense i
was like who shot that from above i thought like someone
shot from above me
there you go I think I got all the high ground.
What the fuck?
That guy's a little guy.
How did he survive those shots?
Okay.
I mean, surely the...
There we go.
Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Oh, serpentine!
Serpentine!
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
Oh, there he is, too.
Oh, I don't like that sound.
Where are those sounds coming from?
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, that was a fucking headshot.
Come on.
No way he sees me.
Must be like, where did those shots come from?
Are you fucking...
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, god damn it.
Okay, that's fine.
There you go.
It's okay, I can recreate this.
Are you serious?
Serpentine, serpentine.
There you go.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Where are the others?
Backshot.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, we need the other gun.
It's okay.
Just keep doing the loop-de-loops.
They don't know.
I got you, buddy.
Oh, I do not got you anymore.
I do not got you no more.
Oh, fuck.
There we go.
I got you, bro.
Just keep looping.
Let's keep looping.
You got this.
You think he's still alive?
Wait, guys, I don't see.
Oh, he's still fine.
He's still alive.
Just keep looping, bro.
They don't know.
There, I cover you.
There you go.
Cover fire.
Where are they coming from?
Holy shit.
They still keep coming.
Where are these snipers?
Shoeing up
Just keep looping it always work trust
See see I told you just needed to keep looping look at that
they're all dead Let's steal their sniper rifle Oh wait,
there was the there was the uh attack rifle back there I
really want their sniper Yeah, the battle rifle.
Let me grab this and now grab the battle rifle.
I can double zoom?
Oh my god, I can double zoom.
Okay, but it's more impressive that I hit those headshots
without using a crutch.
The double zoom crutch.
Guys, it was more...
Oh, wait, with a sniper rifle, though.
Okay.
all right the double sniper meta this level reminds me of an
old family guy joke a jackal a jackal it's a jackal it looks
like a jackal that's a thing of a super chat thank you thank
you look see everything is okay a double sniper where do we
oh we must go this way right hey guys no no no oh it's oh
wait no i do not want to No.
No, it's okay.
I don't want to be on the burning truck.
I think it's fine.
I think it's fine not being on the burning truck, guys.
Are you fucking kidding?
Wow!
Okay, yeah, no, that guy's dead.
Yeah, that guy's fucking dead.
Wait, did he did it?
Did he kill the ghost?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
All right.
How do we kill that, though?
Oh, my God.
We're so...
He was so low.
How do we kill that?
Well, I don't know how to kill that.
Oh, nice friendly fire?
I'm just gonna kill the car.
It should explode, right?
Well, now it should.
Well, I thought it would explode, but guess not.
Oh, the hog can kill it?
I believe in him.
I'll go find another.
I gotta re...
I gotta swap weapons.
There are all the snipers that I killed earlier.
There they are.
Alright.
I need...
Bro, the car's on fire!
The...
Guys!
The car's on fire!
I don't know about...
Wait, what happened to the car?
Oh shit.
How?
Just a get it.
Guys, where's the turret?
Wait, where did these guys come from?
Oh, fuck.
I'm worried, they don't know.
We're so confused.
All right, I'm gonna ride this ghost And then go straight
into the tank And then Get off it Oh shit Get off it And
then Board Board it, that's right Wait It's mine now Oh, I
didn't realize I had more instructions I did guys, I didn't
realize instructions unclear Oh, and then that's the grenade
and then it's yay
holy shit wait this this is ass
what oh shit my my tank let me use it let me use a tank as
cover it real quick guys surely nothing's gonna go wrong If
I use a tank for cover.
It's surely, right?
See, it was fine.
I do need to use my names more.
But then I'm so ass with the names.
Look at that.
I live.
Oh, look, see?
He was just ahead of me.
Okay, I keep thinking I'll hit that.
All right, we're gonna get...
Wait, what?
Oh, what the fuck?
I was like, I thought we were on the same team!
Why did he shoot me?
All right, get off this truck!
Get off!
My turn!
Go walk!
Wait, I never saw a sound guy's response if the audio was
fine or not.
I never Wait, give me a sec.
I just realized Oh sound is good.
All right, nice sound is good.
All right, let's go
All right No, it's fair.
I trust my AI there are a number of Marines trapped in that
building What building They're the biggest threat.
Am I doing anything to it?
Am I...
I hope I am.
Oh, you're driving me.
I let you take the wheel.
I...
Oh my god, I got fucking ran over.
I got ran over by my own car.
Okay, I'm getting off.
Wait.
What?
Who's shooting me?
Alright.
Alright, it's fine.
He's going straight in with no...
No one to shoot it.
I believe in him.
Here, I have to take out the snipers first.
And now go back in.
Okay, I think all the snipers are gone.
There are a number of Marines trapped in that building.
What building?
on the raids they're the biggest threat oh this building you
know i should be able to walk over there the truck is
distracting him should be fine there's no way they got me
look i'm sneaking behind them, too, right now.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Boom!
Why did you run me over?
Why did he run me over?
They're the biggest threat.
they deserve what did I do to deserve that I don't
understand I've been fighting for my planet all right just
casually just walk up to them should be fine there we go
boom boom boom boom get in there I'll watch, too.
Get out of here.
Boom.
I'll punch you until you're out.
All right, nice.
Okay, no longer nice.
I'm already dead.
I'm just...
I'm under the reins, trapped in that building.
Concentrate on the wraiths.
They're the biggest threat.
What's the second planet is he fighting for?
Guys, I think there's a...
I think there's a fucking spy in the ranks.
I...
Guys, there might be a spy among us.
There might be a fucking...
Double agent.
How did he kill us?
He's like, gotta get that double tap.
There we go.
Boom!
How dang it, if it's, or it won't destroy, why?
Oh, wow, I'm on it.
Really?
Okay, now you tell me.
That's alright.
We're doing a little loop-to-loop right now.
Can I get in?
Ah!
Please!
Alright, it's fine.
I'll just stay in here.
Mickey here.
I'll just stay on the hog.
I'll just stay on the ward hog.
I've given up.
I'll give it up.
I'll I'll just shoot at it now.
Okay, I want to kill the sniper first.
Oh, we're just leaving?
I mean, that's cool, I guess.
Where is he me.
Where the fuck is he taking me?
Where are you?
Oh, now you don't want to drive into them.
I see how it is.
I see.
Okay, buddy.
Oh, fucking kid.
Any minute now.
Any fucking...
He did it.
All right, let's get it off.
All right, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
There we go.
It's not expecting this though.
Watch this.
Whaaah!
Bam!
Get out of here!
Oh god, oh god, it's looking at me right now.
just looking at me.
Come on.
Oh my god, my hero.
Get out of your soldier!
I can't.
Okay, wait, I have a plan.
Oh shit, wrong gun.
It's alright.
It's okay.
Wrong gun.
Oh my god, not hitting anything.
Oh shit, goodbye.
We have an idea.
I Have an idea.
Oh my god, get that goddamn warthog out of my game
Watch this Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Oh, no, don't get me closer.
All right.
I'm out of these Whoa, I'm out of here all right watch this
okay it's gonna be so sick wait wait a minute it looks like
it's aiming at me wait watch boom no
kobe okay okay wait oh wait it'll it'll hit it don't worry
it's like a carnival game
It's like a little it's like a little carnival game.
I could get it in the hole.
All right, that's fine We'll just It was a nice idea I
thought it would look so cool.
No, no, not again.
Not it It's okay.
It's okay.
We made it.
We made it my turn Round two.
What do you mean I'm getting shot in the sky?
Who's shooting me?
I'm committed.
Get me out of here.
What the fuck?
What do you mean there's a second round?
What do you mean?
I thought...
It's okay, guys.
nothing to worry about there's no oh and then he's just dead
he what do you mean there's a phase until
where are they coming from it's okay I got this it wasn't
worth I thought it would be over the moment I killed the
tank they're like everybody he stopped the tank is gone it's
all right it's fine okay and then i'll put this here and
i'll get off and then i gotta book it oh my god look at that
perfectly predicted perfectly fucking predicted and then
i'll get into the tank i guess i won't get into the tank i
I guess, I guess I won't.
Guys, I...
What?
What is that a second tank?
When were there two more tanks?
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Why are there two...
When was there two other tanks?
I don't have any more vehicles they all died I they killed
my tank they instantly shot the warthog what the fuck was I
supposed to do I've never seen this third tank before in my
life I've actually never seen the third tank before for this
is the first time oh no no no no no no no i just got ran
over it was a vehicle sandwich all right here we go i'll
i'll try again you know what i have an idea i have an idea
all right you you don't drive no more all right get in all
right here we go i'm relying it all on you soldier
This tab...
This is all you, soldier!
Okay, this tab.
Alright.
I'll get him closer to this guy for him to do anything.
There we go.
Not too bad now.
There are a number of Marines trapped in that building,
please.
Concentrate on the race.
They're the biggest threat.
I am sorry.
stuck in my own personal Groundhog Day right now.
I really am.
This is my own personal hell.
This is my own.
I'm not too mad.
I did the most.
How does they do they keep shooting me?
That's it.
Nope.
Do not get on there.
Get soldier.
Soldier.
Get on there.
I need you to get.
Soldier.
I need you to get on the warthog.
I...
There are a number of Marines trapped in that building.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Like, what's the point?
Wait, wait, he's gonna drive it.
Wait, he's gonna...
He's gonna...
Bro.
You can just be there, I guess.
That's five.
That's it.
It is what it is.
There's only one rave.
I think the game felt sorry.
Oh, no, never mind.
Peek-a-boo, you thought it was only one rave.
Oh, you really thought it was only one.
I really thought.
I really is it.
Are you serious?
He's still alive in there?
How is he still alive?
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
I just didn't realize he'll still be alive.
That was an oopsie on my part.
I really thought he'd be dead.
There are a number of marines trapped in that building too.
I was full confidence that he was gonna be dead.
I was so confident in that.
Alright, distract him, Carr!
Not run over the men!
That's my job!
Alright, it's fine.
I'll throw two grenades in there.
Surely that will work.
there we go get in get in oh my god oh my god oh my god wait
okay wait this is five we're doing it we have better aim
i think i think i'm hitting the shots is it working it's
working I think it's working guys.
I boosted into it.
I'm back.
I fucking exploded with it Blood and welcome to the tomato
bar.
Wrong button.
Wrong fucking button.
All right, I might have accidentally pressed oh, okay, it's
all right.
I pressed the wrong button.
That's a little oopsie on my part.
All right, I got this trap, though.
I got this trap.
We punch.
We keep punching until...
And then, Nade!
Nade!
And then, get off!
And then, get on!
It only took me 80 tries.
Okay.
Tank on tank.
Tank warping.
the only issue now is that we just gotta we just gotta make
sure just gotta make sure we're not next to the tank when we
do this oh god oh god i'm jiggle peeking i'm jiggle peeking
a tank right now i i think i'm hitting him i can't tell oh
wait i am it's smoking There we go.
Peaking corners?
There we go.
That's right!
Get bridged!
That's fucking right!
I know, I knew it.
Guys, I knew that bridge.
That bridge is fucking with them right now.
They don't know how to shoot it!
My god.
How many fucking hits are they?
Do they goddamn take?
Oh, shit.
My tank.
Sorry, my tank's okay.
Okay, I know.
I know I win the bridge warfare.
They're still alive.
How are they still alive?
I don't understand.
I just keep shooting.
It's just all blue.
Okay, now I'm Now it's dead.
Alright, that's good.
Alright.
Alright, now is the ship.
Here we go.
There, I learned.
I learned from this.
There we go.
We made it.
We fucking made it, guys.
How is that ship still?
This tank's still alive!
Oh my god, just stop!
It's over!
It's fucking over!
Just stop!
Oh my god, the Marines are coming in.
They're like, we waited long enough.
The Marines are like, any minute now, Doki.
Any minute.
There we go.
We did it.
We made it.
I'm bringing this.
tank with me.
Do you think he's okay?
Alright, I parked it.
I think I parked it perfectly.
Oh, I was in the...
Oh, there we go.
I think I parked the tank perfectly.
I don't need york any guns.
I got all the guns I need.
My double sniper.
I'm in the loop.
I worked so hard bringing this to getting this tank.
Oh, trouble.
Holy shit, look at those legs.
You think he's gonna shoot us?
Oh, goodbye, soldier.
Goodbye.
Oh, I'm supposed to shoot it.
Oh.
Okay, to be fair, I thought I was gonna leave them to die.
I don't think it's stopping.
Just our heads down.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Oh, it's fine.
It's just leaving.
Oh, is that the scarab?
Oh.
It's the scarab.
Okay, I thought I was supposed to shoot it because it opened
its mouth.
So I was just like, oh, I shoot that, right?
So that's the 40-plus minute to wanted me to do wait I could
jump this watch this now what do I do now that I'm on it oh
shit I'm
not dying to you oh shit maybe I'll die to someone else oh
fuck come on come on oh fuck
whoa oh god where am I
that's right from the skies holy shit okay I didn't expect
80 people to drop by okay that that that I was a little
oopsie.
I didn't think 80 people are going to show up.
Maybe the melee run was not it.
Maybe.
I realized I should not have done the melee only.
Boom!
I should have got nays!
Nays!
There we go.
Oh.
Here's some more nays.
Oh, I don't have one shot.
I mean, it's still one shot.
It's still counts.
There you go.
Oh, reserve.
Oh.
Sorry, I'll just stay up here.
Where are you going to do?
Push me?
Oh, my God.
I gotta wait!
No!
If you have one shot...
Oh, fuck.
He pushed me!
Who could have expected that?
How was I supposed to know?
He would do that!
Alright, let's grab him.
I still like the sniper rifle, I will say.
I think the sniper rifle comes in clutch.
Oops.
What?
No.
There was a rocket launcher!
Wait, where is it?
Where's the rocket launcher?
Where the fuck is this rocket launcher?
Oh my god.
It was always here.
I don't know if I'll make it.
Alright, there we go.
Nice Nice
Doesn't know It's so stupid Okay Oh come on bro Are you
serious?
Alright so Boom!
Oh shit Boom!
let me just it's okay I'm just recharging my shield oh
that's fine fuck okay
boom oh fuck that's so many I didn't realize they're extra
oh my god there was extra ammo okay wait now that I know I
know the strat now guys know that's trapped okay you get rid
of that and then and then it's fine wait where's the ammo
wait it's not gonna run away right all right oh i can board
whenever i
wait a minute i can board whenever the fuck i want Oh shit,
okay.
That makes things a lot easier.
That really does.
I didn't even realize that.
There's a second area.
Oh my god, there's a third pillar too.
Oopsie.
Oh yeah.
But you ain't no coward, right?
No, he?
I didn't realize there were more to this.
Wait, let me see.
Would that hit?
Okay, that clearly did not hit.
Alright, final defense!
I ran out of ammo.
Give me that.
Alright, we're going in.
Holy shit, it's just all red!
How did I get placed off?
I swear, I swear, guys, I didn't move.
It actually just pushed me off.
It actually pushed me off.
I swear to God I didn't move at all.
I swear to God.
I swear to God I didn't move.
It actually just pushed me off.
What?
Is that not ammo?
Oh, there's ammo.
Where's my other ammo?
What the fuck?
Where the fuck is my rocket launcher ammo?
Oh my god.
I'm just sniping with the other sniper.
I...
Don't worry.
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out.
Grab this.
That's the battle rifle.
We grabbed this.
Bum.
I just wanted to look.
Look, the soundtrack's pretty sick, though.
It says, oh, God.
Guys, what the soundtrack, though?
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I, I, it must have.
hit something, right?
It must have hit something, right?
There we go.
Like, I'll take that.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Oh, shit.
Oh shit guys, I have no more guns.
I give me that give me your gun
Okay There you go
There you go.
We're doing it.
We're doing it
Oh my gosh, the shot.
Oh shit It's okay.
It's okay.
It's okay Oh
Oh my god, it's okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh shit.
Okay everything's fine
Are y'all dead?
Is he dead?
I can't see I shoot him in the booty
Wait, oh fuck He flanked it that's illegal He shot me in the
booty!
Who could have expected that?
There we go.
That's one badass.
That's fucking...
What the fuck did you do?
Distract the chief and return to an amberclad.
Sir, the Prophet is bugging out.
Request permission to engage.
Negative, Commander.
Oh,
damn!
Slip space rupture on the target's bow.
Swap the graphics.
There's no time, sir.
Green light.
Green light to engage.
Punch it.
Get us close.
Ma'am, without a destination solution.
We are not losing that ship.
Oh,
wait, there was no one else on that planet, right?
We're not losing this ship.
I guess we're going to lose this planet.
Yeah.
That's our...
I'm joking that.
can't lose the planet i lose the ship guys you can't lose
the ship though yeah that climbing surely isn't that
important right i'm joking that's
he's not meant for the jails the hierarchs have something
special in mind
honestly for earth's defenses that's pretty He defends.
Huh?
Noble prophets of truth and mercy.
I have brought the incompetent.
You may leave, Tartarus.
But I thought...
And take your brutes with you.
Damn.
Oh my god, forgot he was naked.
I'm so uncomfortable with the naked worm.
He looks just like me yesterday.
of your execution are up to me i am already dead indeed do
you know where we are the mausoleum of the arbiter quite so
here rest the vanguard of the great journey every yeah but
at least i wasn't lucky each one created and consumed in
times of extraordinary crisis the taming of the hunters the
grunt rebellion were it not for the arbiter's the covenant
would have broken long ago.
Even on my knees, I do not belong in their presence.
Halo's destruction was your era, and you rightly bear the
blame.
But the council was overzealous.
We know you are no heretic.
This is the true face of heresy, one who would subvert our
faith and incite rebellion against the High Council.
Our prophets are false.
Open your eyes.
Heretic!
They will use the faith of our forefathers to bring ruined
to us all the great journey blasphemy kill him and those who
follow him must be silenced their slander offends all who
walk the path what use am i her say we gotta kill him lead
troops into battle not as you are no but become the arbiter
and you shall be set loose against this heresy with our
blessing to be an arbiter that's the highest honor oh that
way that's sick what of the council the tasks you must
undertake as the arbiter of parents suicidal you will die as
each arbiter has before you the council will have their
corpse I live and die for the swarm Sorry, wrong game.
Ward, Ward.
Thank you and shame in front of two old men in Musilium.
Just like me on Wednesday night.
Brian, thank you.
Let's pretend.
Thank you.
Ward, Ward, Ward.
According to our station, all without exception.
On the blood of our fathers.
On the blood of our sons.
Oh my god, it's the white eye.
Where are we?
Even to our dying breath.
Those who would break this oath are heavy.
Worthy of neither pity nor mercy.
Even now, they use our Lord's creations to broadcast their
lives.
We shall grind them into dust.
And continue our march to glorious salvation.
This armor suits you, but it cannot hide that mark.
Nothing ever will.
You are the arbiter.
The will of the prophets.
But these are my elites.
Their lives matter to me.
Yours doesn't matter.
That makes two of us.
They're not just mindless aliens.
But my propaganda.
What do you mean they all have friends and families?
And passions.
And ideals.
They told me they have nothing.
They just have their mindless freaks of nature.
AI.
They're here to confuse me.
They have hobbies?
And, oh my God, I'm an alien!
Oh, what?
What?
Can't be real.
It's AI.
Oh, no.
Don't fall for the lies, Doki.
oh shit we have a sick ass sword now it's okay they have
army regens hey dude well they give a magenta soup but they
can think oh no I became what I hated the most oh no I'm a
goddamn Zeno I might accidentally
Sorry, it was a force of habit.
I was so...
You don't understand, guys.
Wait, I can go invisible?
I'll try to turn on the flashlight.
It's so dark.
It's okay, I have this.
If it's too dark, I'll just change my graphics, guys.
I couldn't help it.
I've been killing aliens all day.
Change active camouflage.
Reveal yourselves only after the arbiter has joined battle
with the enemy yeah it's so cute he's guys he's a grunt but
take your armor system is not as new as ours your camouflage
will not last all right wait what's my cool down my fucking
camera oh there it is okay look at they're shooting at each
other they're shooting at each other guys they're they're
shooting each other guys You can't tell me.
There we go.
I have to.
Okay, never mind.
It's equally as dark.
Where are they?
Where did I get shot from?
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
Wait, they're bad guys?
Oh, I can't tell if they were...
I forgot.
I'm killing the heretics right now.
It's hard.
They look just like me.
So that means I just gotta kill all of them.
I have an idea.
As long as I...
If I kill all of them, then...
One of them has to be the heretics, you know?
I'll get it, right?
I'll get it right eventually.
Oh, shit.
all right you want to say that again all
right oh my god oh my god no
all right they should wear different colors that's all i'm
saying it would be a bit easier if if they wore different
color armor Tokyo's already different no if they were naked
it would have been easier.
It's like, it's like, what is it?
It's like, skins versus shirts?
You gotta make it skins versus shirts.
They literally are.
Not naked enough.
Don't you not now.
What the fuck?
Okay, that should have killed them earlier.
Oh my god!
Wait, that's not fair!
Where am I?
Alright.
It's fine.
I know how to play this now.
Oh shit.
I know what to do now.
It's difficult, guys.
I was so used.
Being one of them is throwing me off.
After everything I was taught in Halo school.
I didn't realize I have to be them now.
Oh my god, there we go.
Oh my god, there's so much HP.
Jesus.
How is he still?
Oh my god, fuck this.
Fuck this.
Yeah, I said to get rid of Lil, guys.
They have the spike guns.
That shit hurts.
Maybe it'll roll down.
They didn't roll down, guys.
There we go.
It's nice of them to jump for me.
Like, in that goddamn corner.
It's very nice of them to do that.
I really appreciate that jumping.
Alright.
Wait, what?
They shot me while I was mid-gammo?
Okay, that's bullshit.
Double kill!
Okay, that won't stick me, though.
There we go.
Got the double.
Alright, gotta get that.
Slap that alien out of here.
Alright.
I don't know.
realize there would be a alien level.
That's cool.
A little bit different, you know?
I like the variety.
Get out of here.
Holy shit, he's alive!
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no, no!
I didn't think there'd be a swarm.
I thought I was killing, like, five to seven people.
Not an entire goddamn army.
I thought everyone believed in what I believed in.
There we go.
Entire cult.
We're the cult here.
What do you mean there's more?
He gained followers.
Bots.
Godfrey.
I bet he bought you bots.
What is this entire covenant?
Blasphemy.
The other called wait i have ammo for my oh my god i forgot
my sword has ammo i've you would assume a sword is a sword i
should have maybe been cloaked oh shit oh no now there's
robots too this is bad i don't just i was like oh shit wait
a minute i should have been Yeah,
but it could be solar powered.
You know?
Ah, I might have.
Okay, I can reset the cloak timer.
You know?
Powered by mine.
I just raised it to the sun.
Okay, this is a little bad.
There we go.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even know where they found me.
Oh, my God.
How did he find me?
I don't understand.
How did he see me?
Yeah, I thought I would have brought the charger with me.
You know?
Oh, my God.
How am I here?
I didn't bring my charger.
My energy.
My sword charger.
You know?
It feels like it'd be something I should have brought.
Wait, you're still alive?
Oh my god, you fucker!
Oh my god!
I'll kill you instead.
Really?
You're gonna walk all the way there.
You fucking pussy.
You out.
Do I like...
Where did my sword go?
Damn.
Okay, I don't know where this fuck my sword disappeared too.
Brave Sir Zeno ran away.
Okay.
Will I be able to find more sword ammo?
Well, it's time to find out.
Where did he go?
There he is.
I have zero hits now.
No?
Oh, shit.
You would think these goddamn traitors will have more sword
ammo.
Open all hangers.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen.
Oh, you can't recharge shields?
What the fuck is the point?
Okay.
Wait, that's my team.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'm gonna have to grab more needlers.
Wait, what's that?
Swap to hands?
What the fuck is this?
It's a Zarya beam?
It's the exploding beam.
Okay, the exploding beam is garbage.
Okay!
Oh, 80 people just showed up.
Alright, I didn't expect 80 fucking people to show up in
front of me.
Oh, that's my...
Guys, I can't tell.
I just see aliens.
I'm so...
Oh, okay, they're my team.
Okay, they were part of my team.
Okay, okay.
That's fine, that's fine.
I'm sorry, it's just reflex.
I've been...
It's just reflex at this point.
I'm so used to killing all of them.
Oh, that's a sniper.
Can you blame me, guys?
Can you really blame me?
My entire life mission was to kill them.
And now you want me to stop doing that?
All right.
They literally destroyed Earth.
Guys.
That's where we live.
Okay, more heretics.
Okay, I see them this time.
Guys, I see them.
Red is bad.
Wait, he has the sword.
Oh!
My god.
I thought I could take it.
I thought it was... I don't know.
I just thought I was built different, I guess.
I legitimately thought I was built different.
There we go.
Now!
Now I have the sword.
Here we go.
There we go.
I got my sword charger.
There you go.
Alright, we gotta cleanse.
Cleanse our ranks.
Kill the non-believers!
Wait, actually is that sniper?
Wait, one of them's a sniper.
I saw it.
Whatever, I'll grab the needle.
It's fine, we'll just kill the bronze.
They should explode.
I'm not using my sword on the goddamn grudge.
Okay, I'm using this.
Okay, who threw the nade at my back?
Okay, one of them?
I know for a fact that they weren't the ones that...
Oh my god, that's my team.
That's my team.
That's my fucking team.
That...
I know the fact that it was one of you guys.
It was a goddamn team kill!
I
can dual wield this.
I feel like it'd be good.
See, guys, this is why I don't trust them.
They're making...
They're giving me a chance to not trust them.
I forgot to...
I forgot I have to press both buttons.
Look, you're not giving me a lot to work with here, guys.
There you go.
Now where am I, huh?
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'll see you on high ground.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is actually fine.
Shit!
I know you're here.
BAM!
All right.
Oh, it's just a regular carbide.
I don't know why I thought that was a sniper rifle.
I always feel like I keep thinking it's the sniper.
Okay, that's my teammate.
I keep thinking it's the fucking sniper rifle.
That's- oh, that's the carbide.
It looks just like the sniper!
We're just gonna go take the high ground.
Yeah, it's the battle rifle.
It looks like the sniper rifle sometimes.
Like the shape of it.
He should be over here.
Wait.
You think high ground is gonna save you?
What the fuck?
What hurt me?
Like, what hit me?
What is hit?
Oh my god!
What?
Oh, no.
Wait, that's the enemy.
Okay.
Wait.
Are you fucking... Okay.
That's fine.
I'm reloading.
Wait.
Do I see you?
Boom!
I got you now!
Okay.
Where's the last guy?
all right the last guy is right in this corner i know where
you are that's right i know where you are that's oh he's
dead okay he's dead all right that's fine he just he just
decides to just let gravity take him
okay that should just straight up just murder him no no no
no all right can you keep coming over it though you want oh
this is bad for me my entire team die maybe
oh they're all dead yes yeah there we go all right we'll
just go this way See, this keeps, this looks like the sniper
to me.
Because it's like, it's long, like the other one.
Okay, I thought I...
I thought I... I had the...
It's hard to tell.
I'm invisible, guys!
It's so hard to tell when you're invisible!
oh my teammates threw the nade again my team my teammates
come from they threw the name they threw the nade I'm gonna
say where the fuck did they come from wait was that the
actually I can't I can never tell which one is which was the
enemy and which one is who's on my team and who's not it
gotta where it gotta be red and blue guys they gotta make it
red and blue that's all i'm gonna say they gotta
make this easier to distinguish
i keep getting lost in the sauce
Maybe it'll be easier to tell.
Nope.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Oh, what?
Alright.
That should technically kill him.
For the sheer amount of needles alone?
He's tiny.
He has less healthy ratio than me.
Yeah, I want to do a double kneelers.
Like, he's shorter.
Wait, what's this?
Oh wait, I want...
I feel like this should actually kill them more, but
whatever.
Just grab the double kneeler for this.
There's too many of them around here.
There's too many down there.
There we go.
Oh, you're still alive.
You know what?
There.
Give me your back!
Somebody's about to get back shot!
Oh, hey.
New sword.
Wait, double sword?
Aww.
Oh, yeah, I used this sword.
Oh, my God.
They just left their sword charger here.
Just like that.
Is that...
Is he dead?
Is he sleeping?
Can't tell.
just in case oh shit
oh that's my team that's my team that's my team
I can't help it I don't know whenever I see them I just see
red I whenever I see them I was like alien I
Oh yeah.
Oh,
he's already dead.
Nice.
Don't understand.
I've been trained.
shoot them all and now i'm supposed to not shoot them
it's just muscle memory
there you go what the fuck my entire life i was told they
were the enemies now they're not except for some of them oh
my god i was invisible at first
yeah just turn it off
oh wait they're all dead what the wait there you go oh i
hope that's so much fucking solid thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you
Where am I?
Oh,
wait, I can see it now.
I can...
Alright.
Nice, we're both regenning.
Regen!
Deal with him, my brothers.
I will defend the Oracle.
Its truth must not be
oh my god get out of here get out of here
okay i have my team my team's here
oh my perfectly tracked by the way oh oh oh guys i thought
he was a spy i thought he was a spy guys I thought it was a
spy I was like that's what a heretic would say you know
that's what a heretic was saying oh yeah if it was you tell
me who do we worship what color are we what colors the enemy
okay a death penalty he didn't say the secret code word you
know you know when we're trying to make sure that there's no
spies he didn't say the secret code word guys you know when
we're like okay to make sure that none of us are spies you
gotta see that secret way so you wouldn't get shot and he
did it can you really blame me holy shit oh my god i'm doing
a barrel roll can i even that's my ship that's that's my
ship That was my car.
Green donkey!
I was just so used!
I was so used to shooting the other one!
I gotta swap cars.
This car is breaking down right now.
For the classes?
I do?
How do I use it?
How do I use the plasma rocket, guys?
It's like you expect me to just change size, like after
everything I believed in.
Like, come on, guys.
You expect me to just change size?
Just like that!
It's not right click right click is speed speed Or is it
melee?
It's not melee.
Maybe it's grenades.
It's none of that guys.
I can't get the bomb Yes Just go against my training Nope,
not middle mouse
Guys, I actually don't know what the...
Space?
Is it space?
Or is it crouch?
No?
Oh, it's up!
I pressed the wrong button.
I...
I pressed...
It's not E, guys.
It's...
Oh, it's Q, it's Q.
Why the fuck is it on Q?
That is so...
I'm sorry, but that is such a random fucking button to have
it on like No, I was like pressing every random button on my
keyboard.
I didn't even see someone said E I was literally just
pressing everything Because of why because no other button
was Q before Nothing else was fine in the Q before
Oh my god, we go higher.
Like, no one has ever gone.
There's no way.
There's no way I bound this.
I did not bind anything on Q.
It's a bad shield.
She's, you're alting, Doki.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna alts, guys!
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I got it.
Oh, fuck!
That was an accident.
It's okay, it's there.
I didn't mean to do that.
Let's try my route and do the barrel roll and I actually
press E again.
Oh, shit.
The barrel roll!
No!
It's okay.
I landed safely.
Alright.
That's my team.
That's my...
Wait, that wasn't my team!
I fucking knew it!
Wow, I'm doing a barrel roll.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll start ulting.
I'm ulting.
I'm ulting?
Oh, God.
There's no way...
Oh, it got me.
I was like, there's no way my fat fucking plane is gonna get
hit.
Okay.
Wait, I can change ship.
Swapping.
Shield swap.
It's just like my apex.
I'm shield swapping.
I don't know if I can dock on top of it.
I wonder if I can like chill on top.
For science!
It does not work!
It does- Oh my god.
It's okay.
Okay.
it's like those like parasites like the angler fish parasite
and
I'm the I'm the female's body.
She'll protect me.
Oh, fuck.
You guys see I told you.
This is how you ship when a mommy ship and a dad ship love
each other very much.
They do this.
I am a grown woman.
Come on, don't tell me I haven't done this before.
God damn.
Go at it, Sworky.
Oh my god, wait, he did a barrel oil too.
Look away, Jack.
Where the fuck was that guy going?
Wait, I can do a backflip?
Oh my god, I can do this.
Oh my god, how do I stop?
This is my cameo sheep, by the way.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's how we get new ships.
How else are we gonna fucking get new ships, guys?
That's alien biology.
There's a music stop.
Now I can't, I'm pointing back the other graphics because I
can't see.
you're gonna be doing bro yeah you're fucking dead all right
nice all
right we made it oh they were green oh guys i did it it
saves the world i got too into it guys because i don't see
color i i see the the silhouette of what an I mean, what an
enemy looks like.
Oh, oh, no, I broke the cutscene.
Oh, no, I broke the cat.
Wait, I've smelled them before.
What does that mean?
Oh, no, wait, I can restart it.
There we go.
Oh my god, it's so much different.
It's like RTX on.
Right there.
It's so different.
I've smelled it before.
Wow.
I didn't realize the cutscene was five seconds.
Grunge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
We're going to have to call here.
Like I said, I would love to play more, but like I said,
past Doki has left a lot of work for present Doki to do.
It was fun, though.
So don't worry.
Next stream.
Next stream, I'll start recognizing who's on my team.
When I feel like it might be something wrong with me, I
watched Doki for the VTuber stream.
In other words, I perfectly know I look at comparison.
Do you think you would have super chat?
Thank you.
extreme, I'll be able to distinguish the bad aliens and the
good aliens.
Look, my entire life training for Earth, I was only taught
bad aliens.
I never even knew good aliens existed until now.
You can't just undo years of training.
I can't just undo it all.
as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around get that blood flowing and you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys guys it doesn't it's not because i
can't see the green and the red i just see aliens
Bye guys!
Bye!